bei tomaten ist der fall eigentlich
ziemlich eindeutig wenn man die
regelmäßig ausgereizt dann kriegt man am
ende eine dicke rannte aber wie ist das
eigentlich bei gurken bei denen muss man
da ein bisschen differenzieren bei
manchen gurken ist es super sinnvoll
wenn man die auszeit bei anderen kann
man sich die arbeit einfach sparen und
deswegen dreht sich in diesem video
alles und dann müsst ihr mal gucken
aussetzen
[Musik]
ein fall in dem es super sinnvoll ist
wenn man seine gurkenpflanzen ausgereizt
ist wenn man ein begrenztes platzangebot
hat wie jetzt hier zum beispiel im
gewächshaus hier stehen ganz dicht ganz
viele gurkenpflanzen nebeneinander das
klappt nur wenn ich die gurken aus geiz
und ein tribut an einem seil nach oben
leiter bei jeder gurkenpflanzen nur in
die höhe wächst und nicht in die breite
und so passen hier vielmehr
gurkenpflanzen auf eine kleine fläche
außerdem wollen weder dass unsere
gurkenpflanzen die geballte kraft in die
früchte stecken also in die gurken und
wenn wir nur einen trieb haben dann
fließt alle kraft aus der photosynthese
der ganze zucker alle nährstoffe das
ganze gewalt super gut in diese früchte
von diesem einen trieb und das ist ein
großer vorteil vom ausreizen und
vielleicht der wichtigste punkt ist dass
gurken ja sehr anfällig für
pilzkrankheiten wie den mehltau sind und
wie können sich immer dann ausbreiten
wenn nicht so viel luft zwischen den
pflanzen zirkuliert und wenn man die
pflanzen aus geist und vielleicht auch
ein paar blätter entfernt dann kann die
luft da viel besser durch streichen und
die pflanzen wachsen nicht so buschek so
dass sie länger gesund bleiben und weil
es im gewächshaus so schön kuschelig
warm ist wird die ganzen pilzkrankheiten
und man hier auch oft ein begrenztes
platzangebot hat würde ich euch raten
bei gewächshaus tomaten immer aus zu
geizen im freiland sieht das schon ein
bisschen anders aus vor allem die land
burgen die einfach so über den boden
kriechen da kann man relativ bald
sowieso nicht mehr auf zwischen haupt
und seiten trieb unterscheiden und da es
ist auch völlig ruhig die könnt ihr
einfach so wachsen lassen wie sie
einfach wachsen wollen ein bisschen
anders sieht das aus wenn man freiland
wirken an dem rand gerüst hoch leitet
dann kann das manchmal auch ganz
sinnvoll sein die aus zu geizen vor
allem weil sie sonst oft abbrechen
können wenn ihr damit schon mal probleme
hatte dass die früchte einfach zu groß
werden und die pflanzen sich dann nicht
mehr gut festhalten können dann kann es
ganz sinnvoll sein wenn man die gurken
ein tribeca manko ist hoch leitet oder
wenn ihr zum beispiel ganz viele burgen
pflanzen an euer anderes gepflanzt haben
der pflanzabstand sehr niedrig ist dann
ist es auch sinnvoll eben wegen der
pilzkrankheiten die gurken einträge an
dem rang rostock zu leiten aber schauen
wir uns erst mal an wie man so einen
guides trieb denn eigentlich erkennt und
wie man den von dem hauptbetrieb
unterscheidet guck mal hier
eigentlich wie bei den tomaten auf die
ganze macht einen haupt trieb und von
dem auskommen da so abzweigungen das
heißt aus dem haupthaus wächst dann zum
beispiel so ein kandidat hier
und das wäre dann der seiten trieb sehen
wollen wir jetzt entfernt wo es in den
nächten kann es auch mit fingernagel
machen aber der ist jetzt schon relativ
groß beim booten aus hätten unterscheide
ich auch immer auf welcher höhe ich denn
eigentlich geradeaus ganze das peinlich
immer einen in die unteren 50 cm die
mitte der pflanze und den oberen teil
und gerade im unteren teil ist es
wichtig dass man möglichst viele
seitentriebe entfernt weil der boden da
sehr nahe es von dem viele pilzerreger
auf die pflanze übergehen können
deswegen werde ich jetzt auch diesen
großen streep und ihm schon ein kleiner
kocht ansatz ist alles was direkt am
stiel abschneiden so dass das ganze hier
einfach ein bisschen luftiger steht im
mittleren teil der gurken pflanze also
allem was über den unteren 50 cm
er kann man schon ein bisschen
nachlässiger ausgleichen oder ein
bisschen freundlicher weil die betriebe
die hieraus wachsen nicht gefahr laufen
irgendwann den boden zu berühren
das heißt ich habe jetzt keinen
mittleren street gerade aber wenn der
hier gerade theoretisch auswachsen würde
ihr seht ihr hier hängen zwei burg und
fruchtansätze schon dran dann würde ich
einfach nach diese frucht ansätzen im
cut machen hier wächst aus der pflanze
raus und dann kann die pflanze diese
beiden gurken noch großziehen so zu
sagen wir können hier noch was von
ernten und müssten diese fruchtansätze
jetzt nicht verschwenden
das ist also der unterschied zwischen
den unteren getrieben und den oberen
geistigen und wenn die guten pflanzen
dann irgendwann im sommer der fall
laufen ins gewächshaus dach zu stoßen
dann einfach oben die spitze ab kappen
und zwei von den meisten seiten trieben
horizontal weiterleiten so dass da
weiter neue gurken dran gebildet werden
können die pflanze aber nicht in kontakt
zu dem oft feuchten gewächshaus steht
dann auch wieder pilzerreger auf die
pflanze übergehen könnten einen großen
vorteil gibt es übrigens beim kunden aus
geheizten bei den tomaten ist das jahr
gefühlt so eine endlose aufgabe muss
mindestens einmal die woche ran und
mai sind die geilste triebe wieder so
lange bei den birken passiert das nicht
weil die stellen wo man die gurken
einmal ausgesetzt hat aus denen wachsen
dann keine neuen getriebe männer anders
als bei den tomaten und deswegen ist das
kurze auszeit und auch eine viel
angenehmere und schönere aufgabe wo es
viel weniger zu tun gibt trotzdem müsst
ihr euch natürlich mit dem tomaten aus
geheizten befassen und deswegen verlinkt
ich euch gerne da drüben die anleitung
da zeige ich euch genau was man bei den
tomaten beachten muss wenn man die aus
ansonsten geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner grüß mir eure
gurkenpflanzen und wir sehen uns nächste
samstag umziehen für ein neues video
team